that's cardi b's hubby offset
dancing to her hit track up and honestly
the rapper might just be a tick-tock
star in the making
on thursday the wap singer shared this
clip of her man flaunting his moves to
her latest track
up
oh and if that choreography looks
familiar
[Music]
it's because he seemingly got
inspiration from cardi's music video
the clip ends with the migos rapper
breaking into laughter
and cardi she hilariously captioned the
post
quote i hate him ever since the 28 year
old dropped her track earlier this month
fans have been flocking to tick tock to
do the up challenge
[Music]
and if you ask me offset he held his own
well done sir
a supportive hubby we love to see it not
only is offset cardi's hype man
he's also a loving dad to their little
girl you'll really be having her do
whatever the hell she wants
my baby earlier this week cardi shared
that clip of offset giving their
two-year-old daughter culture
a manicure pretty say pretty
excuse me offset are you taking
appointments with other clients because
i'm ready to book and cardi well she's
the
ultimate girl mom guilty the grammy
winner recently
let culture give her a makeover and
shared this video
using her face as a canvas i look pretty
hmm
okay